we're asked to multiply and express as a
simplified rational so when you multiply
any rational expressions it's just like
multiplying any fractions you multiply
the numerators time each other and the
denominators times each other so if we
multiply the numerators here and when
you when you're just multiplying a bunch
of numbers it doesn't matter what order
you do them in and so we want to
multiply an order that makes it a little
bit clearer so we can multiply the
coefficients first so we can multiply 3
times 14
3 times 14 gives us
gives us 3 times 10 is 30 3 times 4 is
12 it gives us 42 so that's the 3 and
the 14.
then we have an a squared
42 a squared then we have a
then we have a b i'll write these in the
order that the letters in alphabetical
order and then we have an x squared and
then we have an x squared so i just
changed the order but i just multiplied
all of these things in both numerators
so that's the numerators multiplied and
let's do the same thing for the
denominator so i'll first do the
constant or i should say the
coefficients so i'll multiply 2 times 18
which is 36
and then i have an a over here
just 1a
36a then i have just one b over here
times b and then i just have one x over
here times x
so we've multiplied the two and now we
just need to simplify them
so let's just think about this a little
bit both 42 and 36 are divisible by 6
that's their greatest common divisor so
let's divide both of them by 6.
42 divided by 6 is 7 36 divided by 6 is
6.
both a squared and a are divisible by a
so let's divide them both by a a squared
divided by a is a a divided by a is 1.
and just remember i'm just dividing in
both in any of these steps i'm just
dividing this the numerator and the
denominator by the same number and
that's not changing the overall value of
the expression
and then i have a b divided by b well i
can divide both the numerator and the
denominators by b
and so i will those those two characters
will cancel out
to just one and one don't even have to
write it when you multiply by one it
doesn't change the value and then i have
an x squared divided by x they're both
divisible by x x squared divided by x is
x
x divided by x is one
so in the numerator in the numerator we
are left with seven a x we can ignore
the b because it's just multiplying by
one now so we have seven
we're doing that same shade of green
we have seven
times a
seven times a times x in the numerator
and then in the denominator we have six
times one times one times one so we have
we have
all sixes now i want to be a little bit
a little bit careful here because if we
want this expression so we have done
what they've asked us to do but this is
it begs a little bit of a question here
if we want this expression to truly be
to truly be the same expression as the
product of these two things we have to
constrain its domain we have to
constrain the variable values here
because this expression right over here
this is defined for any a's or x's you
could put any a or x here and you will
get a value here but this product over
here this was not defined for any a's or
x's the b's cancel out but it was not
defined for any a's or x's in this
situation if either a or x equal to zero
this expression right over here would be
undefined in fact if b was equal to zero
this expression would also be undefined
so if you really want this to be the
exact same expression if say this was a
function definition if you wanted to be
the exact same function definition as
this over here you would have to have it
have the same domain so i'll just write
down the domain here they need to have
the same domain if you want them to be
the exact same function if you don't
care about that then you can just say
okay let's just go with this but you
should constrain it if you want to be an
equivalent and equivalent expression and
so in either case you should constrain
the domain to be
to be all
real numbers
all real numbers and this is a little
bit different because
this is essentially like a two variable
function if you view a is a possible
variable here so all real numbers
for
a
and
a b
a b and x
except
except
a
b
or x is equal to zero so we're just
saying that a b and c can be anything
other than zero and we're getting it
from our original expression after we
multiplied and we're saying if this
needs to be the same it has to have the
same domain most algebra classes they
won't make you be this particular about
it they'll just say simplify the
expression and you'll just simplify it
and you'll give this answer but if you
really want it to be the exact same
expression you would really have to have
the same domain